c'est d'avoir pu pour certains vous
dégagez pour être présents ce matin
et
il ya quand même beaucoup de problèmes
de train donc ça va être je sens une
journée compliquée
donc mes chers collègues nous entendons
ce matin monsieur lui et du soap
ministre du travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion sur le projet de loi
relatif aux mesures d'urgence pour la
protection du pouvoir d'achat que nous
examinerons en commission si tout va
bien le lundi 25 juillet prochain à 18h
en effet si l'assemblée nationale veut
bien nous le transmettre selon le
calendrier prévu
j'indique de cette audition fait l'objet
d'une captation vidéo qui sera
retransmise en direct sur le site du
sénat est disponible en vidéo à la
demande
je salue ceux de nos collègues qui
participent à cette réunion à distance
enfin en l'occurrence je salue jean luc
fichet
monsieur le ministre je vais vous
laisser la parole pour présenter des
articles 1 à 5 de ce texte composite
notre commission étant également saisi
sur le sujet de l'allocation aux adultes
handicapés
ainsi que sur l'article 15 relatifs aux
cdd dans les centrales à charbon
permettez-moi de regretter une nouvelle
fois que le gouvernement n'ait pas jugé
utile de présenter un collectif social
ce qui nous aurait permis de percevoir
plus guerman les effets de ce texte sur
les comptes sociaux plutôt que de
communiquer collectivement dans la joie
comme unis entre guillemets de
distribuer du pouvoir d'achat avant
d'examiner à l'automne prochain les
pandas sécurité sociale et de déplorer
qu ils sont en déficit alors qu'il
manque de l'argent pour l'hopital et
pour la dépendance monsieur le ministre
vous avez là bas
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
madame le rapporteur général mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs d'abord un mot
pour vous dire le plaisir j'ai à vous
retrouver au début de cette 16e
législature pour l'assemblée nationale
et avec la reprise des travaux
parlementaires le texte qui porte
diverses mesures de protection du
pouvoir d'achat
est examinée actuellement l'assemblée
nationale nous étions hier soir en
séance pour l'examen des premiers
amendements sur le premier article et je
forme le même vous madame la présidente
celui que ce texte puisse vous être
transmis dans les délais qui sont
prévues d'abord pour faciliter votre
travail parlementaire mais aussi
permettez moi de le souligner parce que
ça signifierait que pour ce qui concerne
l'examen serait plus rapide que ce que
ce que je crains depuis hier soir à
l'aune de l'examen et du débat sur les
premiers amendements la question du
pouvoir d'achat est une question
centrale centrale à la fois dans les
débats politiques qui ont été ceux qui
ont connu le pays au cours des dernières
semaines mais surtout centrale dans la
vie quotidienne de nos concitoyens nous
avons pris un certain nombre de mesures
pendant le premier quinquennat avec des
baisses d'impôts à hauteur de 25
milliards d'euros pour les ménages avec
des revalorisations dans des emplois
durables sont une ampleur qui n'avait
pas été connus jusqu alors en ce à la
revalorisation de l'allocation adulte
handicapé du minimum vieillesse ou
encore da prime d'activité
revalorisation qui sont intervenus entre
2018 et et 2022 en fonction de
l'actualité et des différents textes qui
vous ont été votées sous au cours ce
premier quinquennat du dernier
quinquennat le pouvoir d'achat a
augmenté plus de manière annuelle et
moyennes keller des deux quinquennats
qui l'avait précédé à hauteur de presque
1% par an c'est un acquis cela
représente une augmentation du pouvoir
d'achat d'environ 300 euros en moyenne
et par an pour chaque français et pour
chaque français les résultats sont un
acquis mais ils ne suffisent pas et nous
sommes aujourd'hui confrontés à une
difficulté très particulière avec le
retour de l'inflation une inflation qui
a des caractéristiques
très propre à cette période puisque
l'essentiel de l'inflation nous
connaissons est une inflation exogènes
que l'on pourrait qualifier d'inflation
exporté dans la importé pardon dans la
mesure où l'essentiel de cette inflation
est justifiée s'explique par
l'augmentation très forte des prix de
l'énergie nous sommes sur une inflation
qui est plus importante que celle que
nous connaissons que nous avons connu
depuis 1985 et des dernières prévisions
de l'insee laisse penser que cette
inflation pourrait atteindre et
peut-être même dépassé
si pensons au cours de l'année 2022 là
aussi nous avons mis en place des
mécanismes des mécanismes de protection
des français contre cette inflation je
pense à la ristourne de 18 centimes par
litre de carburant je pense aux blue
petit et tarifaires sur l'énergie le gaz
nous proposons qu'il soit prolongée au
moins jusqu'à la fin de l'année ou
encore à l'indemnité inflation versée à
plus de 38 millions de français il ya
maintenant quelques mois ces mesures ont
un premier résultat qu'il faut je crois
à souligner notre pays connaît le taux
d'inflation le plus bas de la zone euro
à l'exception de malte est ce cette
inflation que nous arrivons à contenir
est aussi une façon de préserver autant
que possible le pouvoir d'achat des
français le texte que le gouvernement
présente est un texte qui aborde
plusieurs aspects il aborde des aspects
liés à l'économie et à la vie économique
d'autres de mes collègues les
présenteront devant l'assemblée
nationale comme devant votre assemblée
il aborde des questions relatives à
l'énergie et ma collègue en espagne
irina qui aura très certainement
l'occasion de présenter devant le sénat
et il aborde des problématiques en tout
cas des questions relatives aux revenus
du travail et à la manière dont nous
pouvons encourager un meilleur partage
de la richesse produite dans les
entreprises
nous je tiens à le dire avant d'aborder
les dispositions contenues aux articles
1 1,5 ainsi qu'à l'article 15 pour
lequel votre commission a un intérêt
tout particulier
vous n'êtes pas dans le texte ou n'est
pas dans le texte dans la mesure où un
certain nombre de mesures que nous avons
annoncées relèvent du champ
réglementaire je pense aux indemnités
carburant pour les travailleurs et les
grands rouleurs je pense à l'aide
exceptionnelle de solidarité qui
bénéficiera à la rentrée à 14 millions
de personnes ou encore à l'augmentation
du point d'indicé de la fonction
publique augmentation qui prend la forme
pour ce qui concerne sa décision d'un
décret ils n'ont pas d'une disposition
législative dans ce texte nous avons
voulu inscrire ce qui relève du
législatif des mesures qui facilite la
valorisation du travail pour les
indépendants avec une diminution des
cotisations qui permettent de valoriser
le travail par le renforcement des
dispositifs de partage de la valeur mais
aussi de valoriser le travail en
veillant à ce que les différentes
branches professionnelles
revaloriser leurs minima de branche au
titre des articles 1 à 5 et pardonnez
moi si je ne les aborde pas
nécessairement dans cet ordre numéraire
voilà les mesures vous propose d'abord
pour ce qui concerne le partage de la
valeur nous proposons deux mesures une
première mesure consiste dans la
reconduction jusqu'à la fin de l'année
2023 de la prime exceptionnelle de
pouvoir d'achat que certains appellent
parfois la prime macron avec deux
nouveautés d'abord le triplement des
plafonds de 1000 et 2000 euros nous
passons à 3000 et 6000 euros il nous
avons gardé exactement les mêmes
modalités pour le passage du premier au
second plafond que lorsque nous étions à
mille et deux mille euros c'est à dire
la nécessité par exemple d'avoir un
accord d'un accord d'intéressement dans
les entreprises de moins de 50 salariés
pour passer du plafond de 3000 au
plafond de 6000 euros il y à une
nouveauté supplémentaire que je
soulignais qui fait qui a fait l'objet
d'un amendement adopté par la commission
des affaires sociales de l'assemblée
nationale avec le soutien du
gouvernement c'est la possibilité que
cette prime soit versée de manière
fractionnée je précise que le
fractionnement ne peut pas être la
mensualisation pour éviter des effets
d'éviction primes salaires je précise
aussi qu'il ne s'agit pas de créer
plusieurs prime exceptionnelle de
pouvoir d'achat par an dans la même
entreprise que la décision doit être
annuel avec une maintien d'une prime
annuelle mais que pour faciliter des
entreprises qui auraient moins de
trésorerie que d'autres entreprises nous
rendons possible le fait qu'elle soit
versé en plusieurs fois dès lors qu'elle
a été décidée en une seule fois le
deuxième dispositif que nous vous
proposons est un dispositif pérenne qui
pourra concerner les salariés gagnant
plus de trois smic puisque je le
rappelle la paix pas pour reprendre cet
acronyme est réservée aux salariés
gagnant moins de trois smic et donc nous
proposons un dispositif pérenne de
partage de la valeur ajoutée avec une
différence substantielle par rapport à
la prime dite exceptionnelle de pouvoir
d'achat qui est assujetti cement au
régime fiscal et social de
l'intéressement mais avec une plus
grande facilité dans la détermination du
montant à un rythme annuel par
l'entreprise au profit des salariés
la deuxième chose que proposons la
deuxième série de mesures que nous
proposons pour ce qui concerne le
partage de la valeur tian des mesures de
simplification des accords
d'intéressement nous proposons par
exemple de rendre possible la mise en
place d'un accord dès ce matin un accord
d'intéressement par décision unilatérale
dans les entreprises de moins de 50
salariés alors jusqu'à présent c'est
réservé aux entreprises de moins de 11
salariés nous proposons d'étendre cette
possibilité d'accords de décisions
unilatérales renouvellement des accords
de mardin intéressement et enfin nous
proposons de simplifier le régime
administratif des intéressements
supprimons le contrat d'à priori pour
nous concentrer sur des contrôles a
posteriori au fil de l'eau et ainsi
lever un des freins administratifs à la
mise en place d'accords intéressant
voilà pour ce qui concerne le partage de
la valeur j'en viens maintenant à la
question des travailleurs indépendants
pour dire que cette proposition ce
projet de loi que nous vous présentons
prévoit une diminution des cotisations
maladie payées par les travailleurs
indépendants pour que cette exonération
soit totale au niveau du smic c'est à
dire autour de 40% du plafond de
sécurité sociale est dégressive jusqu'à
1 5 smic c'est à dire 60 % du plafond de
sécurité sociale cette mesure représente
un coût total de 320 millions d'euros
pour la sécurité sociale que l'état
s'engage à compenser je le dis car je
sais l'intérêt que porte notre
commission à l'action des compensations
d'exonération décidées par l'état est
porté pour la sécurité sociale c'est une
mesure qui bénéficiera à 80% des
indépendants artisans commerçants
exploitants agricoles et qui pour un
indépendant qui se rémunèrent au niveau
du spic représentera un gain de pouvoir
d'achat de 550 euros par an
enfin il avant d'en venir à la question
des prestations nous proposons des
mesures pour inciter les branches
professionnelles c'est l'article 4 à
maintenir des minima conventionnels au
moins égaux au niveau du smic vous le
savez la revaloriser revalorisation
automatique du smic elle que prévu par
la loi de 2008 on compte amener le smic
a augmenté à date de 5,9 pour cent sur
les neuf derniers mois et la publication
des derniers chiffres de l'inflation par
lindsay amène une revalorisation
automatique au 1er août de 2,0 1% et
ainsi de manière cumulée
seconde sur une augmentation une
revalorisation du smic à hauteur de 8%
sur les 12 mois glissants et un
dispositif protecteur protecteur du
pouvoir d'achat des salariés payés au
smic mais qui a évidemment une
conséquence qui est de voir un certain
nombre de branches
professionnelles afficher des minima
conventionnels inférieur au smic dès
lors que celui-ci augmente et augmente
dans des proportions aussi importantes
que ce que nous connaissons depuis 12
mois à titre d'illustration au 1er mai
lors de la dernière revalorisation du
smic nous nous sommes trouvés face à la
situation suivante avec 145 branches sur
les 171 qui font l'objet d'une
observation attentive par la direction
générale du travail les principales
branches professionnelles présentant au
moins un niveau de rémunération
inférieure au smic à date nous n'avons
plus et je mets des guillemets au
négatif que 99 branches qui ont un
niveau de rémunération inférieure au
smic ça signifie que plus de quarante
branches ont ouvert le travail de
régularisation pour voir des minima
supérieur au smic et que les autres
continuent ce travail de régularisation
nous proposons des mesures de
restructuration de branche ou s'il ya
des possibilités de restructuration de
branche pour inciter les branches a à
faire ce travail là en deux mots si vous
me permettez nous nous proposons par ce
texte d'ajouter un critère aux critères
de restructuration branche imposées par
l'état ce critère serait celui du
maintien durable d'une situation par
laquelle une branche ou des branches
auraient un niveau de rémunération
inférieure au smic je crois qu'il faut
éviter plusieurs écueils dans ce débat
le premier écueil serait de considérer
que cette situation de minima
conventionnels intérieur smic
concernerait presque toutes les
entreprises ça n'est pas le cas et pour
illustrer la aussi mon propos il faut
par exemple avoir en tête que seuls deux
branches sur les 171 présente des minima
ferrero smic depuis plus de 18 mois et
que seulement 17 brouch si je puis dire
présente des minimes inférieures au smic
depuis plus de neuf mois neuf d'entre
elles sont d'ailleurs placés en
commission paritaire pour que
l'incitation nil et à la négociation
soit encore plus forte
le deuxième écueil à éviter serait de
nous substituer au dialogue social nous
tenons à ce que la définition du niveau
des niveaux de rémunération par branches
relève du dialogue social chaque branche
peut procéder à des revalorisations
différencier entre les niveaux pour
donner une attractivité à un moment ou
un autre de la carrière et nous tenons à
ce rôle là enfin nous devons éviter à un
autre écueil qui serait de laisser
penser des salariés en france seraient
rémunérés un niveau inférieur aux spurs
ça n'est pas le cas heureusement la loi
s'applique par contre nous savons que
lorsqu'une branche restent durablement
avec des niveaux de rémunération
inférieure au smic ça signifiait un
tassement des carrières par le bas mais
cela signifie aussi une perte
d'attractivité une perte de perspectives
pour les salariés concernés nous
proposons donc que les branches
durablement qui présentent un niveau de
rémunération ont au moins au niveau de
rémunération inférieure au smic
durablement puisse faire l'objet d'une
restructuration d'office et nous avons
par ailleurs soutenu une disposition
adoptée par la commission des affaires
sociales de l'assemblée qui dit que le
délai de 90 jours à partir du moment où
cette situation est constatée et pendant
lequel les branches doivent si la loi
tel qu'il existe aujourd'hui ouvrir ces
négociations soient ramenés à 45 jours
pour accélérer les négociations après le
passage d'un niveau de rémunération en
deçà du niveau du si
je termine par
3.1.1 prévues par rome le texte à
l'article 5 et 2 points sur lesquels
madame la présidente vous avez dit
l'attention de notre commission
le premier point l'article l'article 5
concerne la revalorisation des pensions
et des prestations pour dire que nous
avançons les revalorisations prévues
soient au 1er janvier sur le 1er avril
au 1er juillet avec un effet rétroactif
et ainsi les prestations sociales et les
pensions seront revalorisées de 4% au
1er juillet 2022 si le parlement décide
ainsi il faut préciser et cette
revalorisation s'ajoute à celle de 1,1
pour cent perçue au 1er janvier dernier
et à celle de 1 8% perçu au 1er avril
dernier lorsqu'on additionne la
revalorisation des prestations sociales
de 1 8% en avril avec celle de 4% que
nous proposons nous arrivons à 5 8% et
donc à un niveau
le niveau prévisionnel d'inflation tel
que prévu et lancé par par l'insee vous
les retraités seront concernés que ce
soit les retraités du secteur privé les
travailleurs indépendants les
fonctionnaires seront aussi concernées
les bénéficiaires du rsa les
bénéficiaires l'allocation adulte
handicapé ceux de l'allocation
spécifique de solidarité
nous incluons les bénéficiaires de la
prime d'activité pour préserver le
différentiel entre un revenu d'activité
et un revenu lié à des minima sociaux
nous intégrons aussi dans les
prestations familiales toutes les
prestations qui sont contenues à
l'article 1 c'est-à-dire indexés sur des
questions d'inflation je pense à toutes
les prestations d allocation
d'accompagnement vers l'emploi je pense
aussi aux bourses de l'enseignement
secondaire
vous m'avez interrogé madame la
présidente sur la question de la hache
et de la déco égalisation de la hache
à l'heure où je m'exprime devant vous je
peux vous indiquer mais avec toutes les
réserves d'usagé que un accord ou en
tout cas une convergence semble se
dessiner entre la plupart des groupes
qui siègent à l'assemblée nationale pour
qu'un amendement puissent être présentés
et adoptés avec un soutien du
gouvernement et qui porterait sur deux
choses d'abord la dea conjugale isation
avec une entrée en vigueur au 1er
octobre au 1er novembre 2023 je suis
prudent sur la date qui a fait l'objet
de discussions je signale à votre
commission que c'est un défi technique
pour les caisses de sécurité sociale que
de tenir ce délai du 1er octobre et nous
prévoyons une deuxième parlementaire
avec le concours du gouvernement prévoit
une deuxième disposition clairement dit
permettant d'éviter qu'ils aient des
perdants puisque s'il a des conjugale
isation étaient appliquées de manière
sèche il y aurait entre 40 et 50 mille
c'est une 40 45 46 mille bénéficiaires
de la hache qui seraient perdants du
fait de la déconvenue égalisation et
donc j'ai indiqué devant la commission
des affaires sociales de l'assemblée que
nous étions favorables que le
gouvernement est favorable ce qui
permettait de lever le gage l'article 40
un dispositif permettant de garantir aux
bénéficiaires de la hache qui seraient
perdants du fait de la des configs
alisation que leurs droits soient
maintenues jusqu'à expiration de ceux ci
de manière à effacer les pertes que
pourrait engendrer 7d conjugale isation
enfin madame la présidente vous avez dit
l'intérêt de votre commission pour
l'article 15 du projet de loi cet
article 15 s'inscrit dans un contexte
qui a trait à la crise de l'énergie nous
prévoyons la possibilité de relancer à
titre cas de prolonger à titre
dérogatoire
l'activité de la centrale à charbon de
saint-avold sur la base du volontariat
or cette centrale à charbon qui doit
fermer dans le cadre des politiques
énergétiques et des politiques de sortie
des énergies carbone que nous menons a
déjà fait l'objet d'un plan social et de
mesures de restructuration de
reclassement et d'accompagnement des
salariés et donc l'article 15 que nous
vous proposons avec ma collègue agnès
pannier rue nasri aura l'occasion de
défendre de votre nom votre assemblée
prévoit que l'intégralité des salariés
qui accepteraient sur la base du
volontariat de travailler pour permettre
à cette centrale de fonctionner autant
que nécessaire et ainsi éviter des
ruptures d'approvisionnement énergétique
l'hiver prochain dans le cadre des
risques que nous connaissons que nous
rencontrons qui sont essentiellement
géopolitique que l'ensemble des salariés
volontaires puissent voir préserver la
totalité de leurs droits ainsi négocié
dans le cadre de la fermeture et du plan
d'accompagnement il y à un pse il ya des
mesures de reclassement il ya des
mesures de congé spécifique tout ça doit
être tout ça a été négociée est acté et
tout ça par la loi sera protégé est
prorogée aussi longtemps que ces
salariés volontaires accepteront de
participer à la prolongation de
l'activité de la centrale à charbon pour
nous aider en matière
d'approvisionnement énergétique j'en
reste là j'ai déjà été trop loin je suis
évidemment à votre disposition des
questions des commissaires
merci monsieur le ministre on va
commencer par frédéric cussac apporte ce
texte pour notre commission et ensuite
filé mouillé chamarré
merci madame la présidente je vais donc
faire court je remercie d'abord monsieur
ministre de sa présence après une nuit
qui fut courte nous avons suivi les
débats également à l'assemblée nationale
alors j'ai pas de doute que nous aurons
aussi des débats dans notre hémicycle je
sais pas s'ils seront de la même teneur
nous vous ferons monsieur le ministre un
certain nombre de propositions
j'imagine de part et d'autre du banc de
l'emi sites qui peuvent être soit
convergentes soit divergentes on verra
ça au cours des débats mais pourquoi est
ce que nous ferons un certain nombre de
propositions non pas tant pour
déconstruire parce qu'un certain nombre
de mesures en tout cas en ce qui cernay
je pense que ça sera le cas de notre
groupe qui me semble être intéressante
mais surtout parce que je considère que
finalement les mesures qui sont proposés
n'ont pas forcément un effet immédiat et
d'efficacité sur le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages et vous l'avez dit monsieur le
ministre c'est un texte qui est
extrêmement attendu et j'ai un peu de
crainte en la matière c'est pour ça que
je me permettrai de vous posé cinq
questions je mets de côté la dernière
qui est l'article 15 / saint-avold je
laisserais mais mes collègues de la
commission économique aborder la
politique énergétique du gouvernement et
par là même les effets induits qui
consiste à détricoter finalement le code
du travail puisque ce n'est ni plus ni
moins que ça en ce qui concerne
l'article case cette question comme je
vous le disais donc d'abord sur l'
approche globale du texte de ce texte
dont le pouvoir d'achat est ce que vous
pouvez nous indiquer le coût pour les
finances publiques de ce texte première
question et par là même j'imagine bien
que les mesures ont été mises en place
au regard sans doute d'un certain nombre
d'études sur l'impact de l'augmentation
de l'inflation pour les ménages donc
merci de me confirmer ce point là et de
m'indiquer s'il ya un reste à charge
pour les ménages si jamais on devait
voter les mesures telles qu'elles sont
proposées aujourd'hui voilà pour la
première question deuxième question ce
qui concerne la prise de partage de la
valeur alors on aura de toute façon un
débat sur cette prime de partage de la
valeur on l'a vu hier je pense qu'on
leur a aussi dans notre hémicycle la
prime versus l'augmentation de salaire
ni au delà de ça la véritable question
je me pose moi c'est la pérennité de ce
dispositif est ce que vous considérez
que ce dispositif est complémentaire des
autres dispositifs de partage de la
valeur à savoir la participation et
l'intéressement
comment avez vous fait ce choix de le
pérenniser et est ce qu'à un moment
donné d'autres questions se sont posées
quand éventuellement une possibilté de
le cap et dans le temps plutôt que de le
pérenniser deuxième question troisième
question en ce qui concerne
intéressement là aussi je trouve qu'il
ya des mesures techniques de
simplification qui rejoignent d'ailleurs
les propositions de l'institut montaigne
qui visait effectivement non pas
détricoter
l'intéressement tel qu'il avait été
j'allais dire
revisité par les différents textes
législatifs qui sont quand même plutôt
plutôt récent avec la crise sanitaire au
passage mais a ajusté un certain nombre
de propositions la vraie question que je
me pose c'est l'effet immédiat
ce dispositif sur le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages j'avoue que cela me semble un
peu loin par rapport aux préoccupations
des français donc j'aimerais vous
entendre sur le sujet quatrième question
en ce qui concerne la fusion
administrative de branches
professionnelles alors nous sommes tous
conscients qu'on a une difficulté assure
effectivement un certain nombre de
branches qui sont en deçà des minima au
smic non pas tant comme vous l'avez dit
monsieur ministre parce que les gens
s'en vont sont effectivement payés au
smic mais parce qu'effectivement il
reste un certain temps sur cette faible
base salariale et que ça pose un certain
nombre de difficultés y compris aux
finances publiques vous êtes bien placé
pour eux pour le savoir mais la vraie
question que je me pose c'est celle
l'efficacité de cette mesure est ce que
vous pensez qu'une telle mesure va
pousser les branches véritablement à
négocier est ce qu'il ya eu
éventuellement d'autres perspectives mis
autour de la table pour pour aller dans
ce sens-là que vous auriez vous pas
évacué et enfin dernière question en ce
qui concerne les indépendants là aussi
c'est une mesure qui était attendu
puisqu'il y avait effectivement une
vraie différence entre les cotisations
des indépendants et des salariés qui
bénéficient d'un certain nombre
d'exonérations dont je trouve que là on
tend vers quelque chose qui est plutôt
intéressant
néanmoins ce que vous pourriez
m'indiquer la mise en oeuvre effective
de ce dispositif pour voir si elle
répond aussi aux effets d'immédiateté
d'attentes en matière de pouvoir d'achat
et enfin une petite question sur l'effet
seuil il nous semble que on est d'accord
pour dire que en deçà 7500 euros de
revenus on aurait une exonération
complète de en l'occurrence de
cotisations maladie et maternité et dès
lors qu'on passe à 24 1700 euros 1 je
crois que c'est le seuil donc c'est à
dire pas bien pas bien loin des 16 mille
cinq cents on l'a tout de suite un effet
seuil puisqu'on passe à peu près à 4 à 4
5 % de cotisations est ce que vous
pensez pas que cet effet seuil pourrait
effectivement tendre à des sous
déclaration voire même à décourager le
travail voilà pour mes cinq questions
même si je vous propose de répondre dans
cette chasse frédéric plus apprendra
ensuite d'autres questions
merci madame la présidente sur les cinq
questions de madame la rapporteure et
dans l'ordre dans lequel elles ont été
posées d'abord sur le coup le paquet
pouvoir d'achat dans son ensemble à la
fois ce qui est contenu dans le texte
que je vous présente partiellement ce
matin et dans le projet de loi de
finances rectificatif et est un
représente un coût global de 30
milliards d'euros dont 20 milliards
d'euros sont des mesures nouvelles et
leur traduction sera dans le pays espère
que vous présenterons bruno le maire et
et gabri natal dans la foulée s'ils
n'ont pas de cette expression de
l'examen du projet doit pouvoir d'achat
est grèce il ya un reste à charge pour
les ménages le crains je le crains parce
que nous ne pouvons pas prévoir de
manière extrêmement précise du niveau de
l'inflation avec des semaines et des
mois d'av ans et nous savons aussi que
cette inflation va se nicher dans des
secteurs sur lesquels l'intervention de
l'état ne sera pas possible mais de
manière générale je crois que ça nous
avons aussi une réflexion sur la
capacité que l'état a et que l'état je
crois démontre de manière extrêmement
forte même si ces partielles à absorber
un choc d'inflation importée nous
faisons nous faisons pour des montants
qui sont incroyablement élevé je pense
au bouclier tarifaires mais il est
évident qu'à un moment ou un autre et
c'est déjà le cas une part des effets de
l'inflation en tout cas du coût de cette
inflation se retrouvera à la fois assumé
par les entreprises mais aussi par les
ménages il serait illusoire et je pense
même démagogie d'expliquer à nos
concitoyens particuliers ou entreprises
que la situation que nous connaissons
avec une inflation plus élevée que celle
que nous avons nous avons connu depuis
1985 pourrait être une situation
totalement indolore et que l'état comme
seul acteur pourrait absolument tout
absorbé sauf au prix d'une dette qui
serait abyssal et non maîtrisée ce qui
je crois n'est pas entendable ni par
nous comme membres du gouvernement aux
parlementaires ni par l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens sur la prime d'activité est
la prime de partage de la valeur par
dont nous avons prévu deux dispositifs
le premier dispositif que nous avons
prévu est une reconduction d'un outil
qualifiée d'exceptionnelle la prime de
partage de la prime de pouvoir d'achat
dont
l'objectif est d'aider et d'aidé de
permettre aux entreprises qui le peuvent
d'aider les salariés gagnant moins de
trois smic
lorsque nous avons proposé dans un
premier temps au niveau de la province
de l'avant projet de pérenniser cet
outil le conseil d'état nous a indiqué
qu'il lui semblait difficile d'envisager
la pérennisation d'un tel outil réservé
aux salariés en fonction du niveau de
leurs revenus c'est la raison pour
laquelle parce que cette prime a
démontré son efficacité
nous avons reconduite toujours avec son
caractère exceptionnel jusqu'à fin 2023
et raison pour laquelle nous avons
imaginé un autre dispositif beaucoup
plus souple que les accords
d'intéressement dans la mesure où il
s'agit d'une disposition d'une décision
annuel permettant de verser des primes
de partage de la valeur à l'ensemble des
salariés quel que soit leur niveau de
revenu mais avec une différence
substantielle qui est que la prime
exceptionnelle le pouvoir d'achat fait
l'objet d'une exonération de cotisations
et de fiscalité alors que la prime de
partage de la valeur et rennes fait
l'objet d'insultés d'un assujettissement
fiscales et sociales sur le même régime
que l'intéressement et donc nous avons
ainsi répondu je crois à une observation
du conseil d'état sur les questions de
principe d'égalité un prix moyen à la
fois à la fois et c'est accepter parce
que cette femelle est temporaire la
reconduction de la paix pas pour
reprendre son acronyme et la création
d'un dispositif nouveau plus souple que
d'intéressement pour permettre le
partage de la valeur et une échelle
annuelle mais concernant tous les
salariés et ce de manière pérenne sur
les questions d'intéressement je partage
la remarque est la vôtre est-ce que
simplifier l'intéressement en la fois
par l'allègement des contrôles
administratifs et là par impossibilité
de décisions unilatérales jusqu'à 50
salariés est un outil particulièrement
performant pour donner un gain de
pouvoir d'achat en l'espace de quelques
semaines la réponse est par définition
négative par contre nous mettons à
profit ce véhicule législatif pour
apporter des simplifications qui nous
paraissent utiles pour favoriser
l'intéressement qui nous paraissent eux
aussi opportune pour souligner combien
nous sommes attachés à ce qu'un maximum
d'entreprises s'inscrit dans ces
dispositifs de partage de la valeur et
avec des dispositifs qui soient pérennes
c'est d'ailleurs le même état d'esprit
qui m'a amené hier soir a donné un avis
défavorable à tous les amendements qui
visaient à supprimer la condition d'un
accord d'intéressement pour passer du
premier plafond de 3000 au plafond de
6000 euros certains amendements
prévoyant près proposons de supprimer
cette conditionnalité dans les
entreprises par exemple de moins de 50
salariés ça n'est pas d'esprit nous
pensons vraiment que l'accès au deuxième
palier comme
outil de facilitation nous vous
proposons vraiment un objectif qui est
structurellement de favoriser
l'intéressement et le développement les
accords d'intéressement dans toutes les
entreprises où c'est possible sur la
question des indépendants et je
terminerai si vous me permettez par la
question des fusions de gauche l'effet
de la baisse de cotisations nous
prévoyons c'est un effet à l'échelle de
l'année 2022 mais qui sera ressentie par
les indépendants concernés lors de
l'appel à cotisation qui interviendra
fin 2022 dès 2023 mais avec un caractère
en termes d'applications rétroactif au
1er janvier 2000 22 ans il y a toujours
des effets de seuil sauf que lorsque
nous passons de 1,6 smic avec un lissage
de l'application de l'exonération entre
un smic et 1,6 l'effet de seuil est
beaucoup moins important que si nous
avions le même niveau d'exonération quel
que soit le niveau de rémunération
versée aux taux versés si je puis dire
par l'indépendant donc le fait que nous
soyons à une exonération maximale au
niveau du smic soit 40% du pass et
qu'ensuite ce soit dégressif jusqu'à
hauteur de 60 % du pass limite l'été de
seuils sans l'effacer totalement vous
avez raison mais chaque fois que nous
mettons en place une telle exonération
il y à des excès enfin sur la question
des restructurations administratives de
branche je pense que c'est incitatif et
je pense que ça le sera particulièrement
pour les entreprises les branches
professionnelles pardonnez moi qui
resteront durablement avec des paliers
de rémunération inférieure au smic ça
nécessite de la volonté politique croyez
moi je les ai compris en termes de
mobilisation et l'animation du dialogue
social cela nécessite aussi une forme de
pragmatisme ne s'agit pas d'ouvrir un
chantier de restructuration de toutes
les branches je lui ai dit dans mon
propos liminaire en réalité moins de 20
broches présente un niveau au moins un
niveau de rémunération inférieure au
smic depuis plus de neuf mois et deux
depuis plus de 18 mois ce qui permet
aussi de relever relativiser le nombre
de branches qui ne serait pas en
conformité avec la loi et le niveau
minimum discours donc nous avons cette
possibilité là en terme de méthode ça
répond je crois votre question sur
l'efficacité du dispositif
nous constaterons l'état constatera le
fait d'être durablement avec au moins un
niveau inférieur au smic
au moment où cette ce constat sera fait
par un arrêté ministériel
l'arrêté sera accompagné du projet de
fusion de la branche avec une branche
proche dans son activité mais
satisfaisant la loi en matière de
rémunération et dans ce cas là la
branche aura un délai qui restera à
définir le cadre d'une concertation pour
ouvrir les négociations et se mettre en
conformité le fait d'accompagner le
constat du projet de fusion et je crois
particulièrement incitatif parce que ça
permet ça oblige finalement elle est
vite sauf à accepter la fusion qui est
ainsi présentée est ce qu'il y avait
d'autres méthodes certaines ont été
explorées et notamment une méthode qui a
été tenté mais qui n'a pas été mise en
oeuvre en 2008 qui consistait à exane à
limiter l'exonération de cotisations
dont bénéficient les branches
professionnelles en fonction de leur
respect des obligations légales en
termes de niveau de rémunération super
supérieurs ou égaux au niveau du smic en
réalité l'expérience de 2008 et les
travaux menés à l'époque mon truc
c'était difficilement applicables
notamment pour une question de principe
d'égalité mais aussi de responsabilité
cela aurait signifié l'application de ce
dispositif une entreprise faisant des
efforts particuliers pour que
l'intégralité des salariés ce pays au
dessus du smic aurait été pourraient
être pénalisés en termes d'accès aux
exonérations du fait de la défaillance
de la branche à laquelle elle appartient
et dans laquelle elle n'exerce pas
nécessairement responsabilité c'est là
où nous avons des difficultés pour mener
à bien ce chantier là il y avait une
variante mais qui se heurte à la même
difficulté consistant à ce que branche
par branche le niveau d exonération ne
soit pas calculé par rapport au niveau
du smic mais par rapport au niveau du
minima conventionnels quand celui ci
d'un ferrero smic mais on se heurte à la
même difficulté de privés ou de diminuer
l'exonération dont bénéficie une
entreprise vertueuses du simple fait de
la défaillance de la branche à laquelle
elle appartient et à laquelle entre
guillemets n'a pas forcément choisi
d'appartenir
remercie alors nous allons prendre
quatre collègues et ensuite nous aurons
une deuxième série de questions alors
fait les mouiller je vous aviez
iacovelli monique lubin fils et mon
loyer personnel présidente monsieur le
ministre mais chaque et qui sont plus
particulière autour de l'allocation
adulte handicapé d'abord j'aurais salué
la volonté du gouvernement à la fois
de revaloriser c'était le question est
bien entendu d'avoir changé d'avis
concernant l'allocation adulte handicapé
j'ai des souvenirs des débats des sujets
de entre ici il ya un an j'ai le plaisir
d'écouter un salon de députés de la
majorité sont des antennes n'expliquant
pas d'augmentation le street au
contraire de ce qu'ils évoquaient eux
mêmes il ya un an mais au-delà de tout
ça je trouve que cette initiative est
intéressante à porte anti char merci de
votre regard bienveillant sur cette
évolution j'ai deux questions concernant
la question du de cap mais c'est la
première concerne le volet budgétaire
dans les travaux que nous avions munis
si nous avions fait une estimation à 580
millions d'euros concernant la dea
conjugale isation à 720 millions d'euros
lorsqu'on intérêt pour la batterie des
perdants donc pour éviter les pannes je
voulais savoir si vous êtes sur les
mêmes orientations budgétaires et
deuxième question dans l'amendement qui
va être proposé à l'assemblée nationale
concernant donc les perdants potentiels
pour éviter les perdants vous évoquez le
fait d'un droit d'option finalement
jusqu'à l'expiration des droits ce qui
est une bonne orientation par contre la
location du cac kpi key aujourd'hui et
parfois verser ou how cook ont signé de
façon à ce que la personne puisse
apercevoir à vide rendre les droits vis
aujourd'hui donc on part qu'on parle de
lait à l'issue des droits est ce que
dans ce cas là ces avis que ces droits
d'option puisse se positionner voilà
donc c'est une question qui joue
l'épousé en cette chaude pour l'instant
un tiers à peu près à première vue ddt
des attributaires de l'allocation des
capitaux concernés par les droits vie
donc je voulais voir l'évolution de
notre marque
toujours sur le tour du handicap cela
concerne notamment l'indemnité carburant
je voulais jvous souffre et que dans le
monde du handicap la saturn de personnes
en méthane mobilité sont obligés tous
les jours d'utiliser leur véhicule soit
par rapport à des ateliers
d'accompagnement dans les instituts
soient pas pour l'instant de rendez-vous
spécialisés et donc seront sur des
publics qui ont des rôles niveau de
revenus très faibles donc est ce qu'il
ya une fenêtre potentiel autour de ce
public là concernant le volet carburants
qui sont pas forcément concernés par des
enjeux autour de l'emploi et la dernière
quand on remarque concerne la prestation
de compensation du handicap
elle n'est pas dans les radars
concernant les évolutions
matière de pouvoir d'achat
alors qu'aujourd'hui réellement les
personnes concernées soient impactés
notamment à travers les techniques alors
concernant les élus mais n'y ait pas de
problématique et les allégations qui
sont automatiques sur toutes les autres
nick wey de l'habitat aujourd'hui une
vraie difficulté donc la question c'est
est ce qu'on pourrait imaginer un regard
aussi sur ce sujet là étant entendu que
si nous le proposons nous sommes article
40 donc ça sera difficile pour nous de
le porter et qu'en parallèle je vous
rappelle qu'un décret récent commence à
regarder l'analyse de la présentation de
deux handicaps en intégrant également
les revenus du foyer donc je voudrais
avoir votre évolution les dc2 si on
gagne d'à-côté h qu'on ne va pas du côté
pch et avec cette évolution voilà donc
c'est sur les deux questions je voulais
aborder merci
merci madame la présidente sue ministre
l'auraient tout d'abord salué la volonté
du gouvernement
de palier des effets effectivement de
l'inflation et de l'effort budgétaire
quand même imposant qui est que vous
avez consentis
néanmoins chez deux questions un peu
complémentaire à aux articles que vous
avez commenté et notamment l'article 3
sur la diffusion de l'intéressement bien
sûr je me réjouis que les petites
entreprises piste désormais en
bénéficier
quand on aura beau tu es bien sûr mais
il avait le président de la république
avait évoqué durant son discours sa
campagne présidentielle la possibilité
d'avoir de verser un dividende salarial
automatique obligatoire pour par toutes
les entreprises qui verserait un
dividende aux actionnaires est-ce que
c'est abandonner ou est ce que ça sera
repris dans un autre texte c'est la
première question est un l'article 5 on
parle de revaloriser évidemment les
prestations sociales sur l'inflation il
avait aussi le président peut parler
d'une automaticité du versement ses
prestations sociales quand
envisagez-vous effectivement de proposer
cette
automaticité merci coup
ça va coller
oui madame la présidente monsieur
minimes et si leurs collègues je
m'associe effectivement aussi à la
question de 2 du sénateur bernard berque
sur la question de la compte de
l'obligation de verser une prime et des
sur dividende si on le faisait pour les
actionnaires et donc pour prouver
salariés donc effectivement je pense que
c'était un projet présidentiel qui en
tout cas moi me aller dans ce que je
pensais et donc je ne le vois pas dans
ce texte est donc je voulais avoir plus
de renseignements juste ça lui est
effectivement la volonté du gouvernement
de maintenir ce bouclier tarifaire sur à
la fois gelé le gaz et maintenir le 4 %
d'augmentation sur l'électricité je
pense que c'était important de le
maintenir quand on sait que dans nos
pays les pays voisins européens
subissent de fortes augmentations sur
l'électricité sont beaucoup moins
d'aidés que ce que nous pouvons à le
faire en france et que nous aurions subi
plus de 44 % d'augmentation sur
l'électricité si si nous n'avions pas ce
bouclier qui qui est donc maintenu une
question sur la prime vous en avez
répondu en partie monsieur le ministre
sur la prime macron cette prime de
partage de la valeur donc il permettra
de tripler en fait de jusqu'à 3000 euros
pour les pour les salariés et 6000 euros
pour l'intéressement il s'agit d'un
engagement fort du prisonnier république
lors de la 2 de l'élection
présidentielle et donc je voulais savoir
quelles qu'elles étaient les contours du
nouveau dispositif et la traduction pour
celles et ceux qui qui vont en
bénéficier et puis
complété effectivement des propos de du
collègue mouillé sur lâche effectivement
à la fois nous avons revalorisé lors du
précédent quinquennat
l'achat 904 euros c'est quand même 12 %
d'augmentation pour 1,2 million de
personnes et donc c'est important aussi
le faire
j'étais de ceux qui se sont opposés à
cette déconvenue gallisa sion lors du
précédent texte et donc je l'assumé
notamment sur la question
dea perdant qu'il y avait donc cette
question et ont maintenant soulever je
suis heureux de pouvoir m'associer à la
majorité sénatoriale pour soutenir
voilà
on ceux qui me connaissent vous savez
mes positions
donc moi je pense qu'il est
effectivement important de revenir sur
sur sept dès conjugale isation juste
peut-être en connaître les contours et
l'impact sur sur le pouvoir d'achat de
ceux qui vont en bénéficient mais unis
si vous pouvez nous en parler et puis
moi j'avais juste une autre question
vous parlez de la rétroactivité jusqu'au
1er juillet de la revalorisation de tout
de ceux de ce texte pouvoir d'achat est
ce que nous arriverons à tenir les
délais
malgré peut-être un peu de retard à
l'assemblée nationale parce que je fais
confiance à la sagesse du sénat pour
pour aller rapidement valider rapidement
ce texte mais au niveau de l'assemblée
nationale ça risque d'être moins sage
est ce qu'on aura on tiendra toujours ce
délai et la possibilité de faire la
rétroactivité au 1er juillet merci
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre moi je voudrais aborder quatre
sujets d'abord je voudrais vous dire que
je trouve que le message qui est envoyé
aux travailleurs indépendants et aux
travailleurs d'ailleurs en général est
assez terrible puisque l'augmentation du
pouvoir d'achat pour ces travailleurs
indépendants passera par une annulation
des cotisations sociales et donc une
rétrocession quelque sorte sur leur
salaire il est évident que lorsque on a
des tout petits revenus de travailleurs
indépendants notamment ribéry zh et
les quelques petites cotisations
sociales que l'on paie et que l'on ne
paiera pas vont apporter immédiatement
un peu de beurre dans les épinards mais
ça ne sera jamais que du beurre dans les
épinards et moi je trouve que le message
qui est envoyé qui consiste à dire à ses
salariés finalement les cotisations
sociales ce sont des charges on vous les
enlève et ainsi vous serez heureux c'est
oublier de l'heure dire quand même que
les cotisations sociales c'est le socle
de notre protection sociale et surtout
de la leur et que ces travailleurs les
plus modestes aux salaires les plus
modestes seront les premiers impactés
par une une un amoindrissement de la
protection sociale pour ce qui est des
décompensations
ces compensations sur les différentes
perte de cotisations sociales vous les
annoncer dans le texte elles sont
annoncés vous venez de vous le dire que
nous dire que il ça concernerait sa 320
millions d'euros je crois et que donc
elle serait compensée vous nous le dites
mais nous n'avons fait rien dans le
texte ne l'inscrit dans le marbre et
donc vous nous dites ça sera le plfss
par quel biais
est ce que le plfss bénéficiera de
nouvelles recettes et dans quelques dans
ce cas-là lesquelles ou alors est-ce que
le plfss conduira à de nouveaux
sacrifices pour justement financer ses
320 millions d'euros
sur le la prime pouvoir d'achat
distribués par les entreprises et
l'actuel mans
quid de toutes ces entreprises qui
n'auront de toute façon pas la
possibilité d'accorder des primes ou
alors des primes extrêmement modeste et
enfin sur lâche moi j'ai juste une
question à vous poser monsieur le
ministre qu'est ce qui a changé depuis
six mois qu'est ce qui fait que il ya
six mois on nous expliquait que ce
n'était absolument pas possible madame
ma collègue et ami rossignol je ne vous
ai pas demandé de répondre
qu'est-ce qui a fait que ce qu'ils
étaient qu'est ce qui était absolument
impossible il ya six mois parce qu'on
avait absolument pas les moyens
deviennent possibles jeu pour ma part
bien que résidant pas loin d'une
certaine grotte je ne crois plus au
miracle depuis longtemps donc voila
j'aimerais avoir une réponse bien
monsieur le ministre
arménien par le miracle
la présidente les miracles ça fait
longtemps que je n'y crois plus donc je
crois même n'y avoir jamais cru
sur sur les différentes questions qui
ont été posées
concernant d'abord l'allocation adulte
handicapé abordé par plusieurs d'entre
vous
la disposition que le gouvernement va
soutenir à l'assemblée qui est une
disposition qui sera proposé par a
priori quasiment tous les groupes
parlementaires je ne sais pas dire tous
même si nous l'espérons pour que cela
puisse marquer à une convergence et un
consensus et est une disposition qui est
sur laquelle la majorité et le
gouvernement gouvernement en particulier
ont évolué depuis quelques mois c'est
une évidence vous l'avez souligné c'est
à la fois le fruit d'une campagne
électorale et de débats et c'est la
prise en compte par le président de la
république l'a dit dans sa campagne d'un
certain nombre de messages et de
rencontres qu'il a pu connaître et qui
l'ont convaincu de bouger sa position
personnelle sur ce point là est de nous
appeler à le faire avec lui moi je dis
de manière très transparente cette
mesure va être bénéfique un grand nombre
des bénéficiaires de la hache elle
pourrait être négative mais le
dispositif de protection à les protéger
et c'est tant mieux elle ne règle pas
nécessairement toutes les questions et
tous les sujets de fond que les uns les
autres nous avons pu aborder
on peut s'interroger sur le fait que la
chaîne un minima social peut être que
d'ailleurs la question est là parce que
la chute a minima social ou pas on peut
s'interroger sur le fait d'
individualisé et donc de des conjugue
alizés le calcul des critères d'accès à
cette allocation pour une allocation ou
à minima social et pas pour les autres
et j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire devant
le sénat à l'occasion du dernier béné
fès-saiss poser la question des étapes
suivantes qui consisterait à dire si
nous des conjugale izon les modalités
d'accès à une prestation une allocation
ce que là où le débat sur la d conjugale
isation des critères dax des critères de
calcul de la contribution à la
protection sociale d'un modèle social il
y a un argument que j'entends et qui
peut me convaincre y compris sur cette
évolution là qui est le fait que
l'allocation adulte handicapé répond ça
envoie la première question sur ce que
c'est un minima social ou pas répond à
une situation qui est une situation par
définition durable alors que d'autres
minima sociaux le rsa par exemple ne
corresponde à un moment de vie
caractérisée par des difficultés
sociales les allocations familiales un
moment de vie caractérisée par l'âge des
enfants là je réponds à une situation
qui est durable et la plupart du temps
non seulement durable n'est figé à
jamais pour la personne qui en bénéficie
mais en tout cas ça ouvre un certain
nombre de questions sur les questions
d'individualisation 2d conjugale isation
et donc sur les modèles fiscaux et
sociaux qui sont ceux que la france a
choisi depuis plusieurs décennies
notamment en matière de solidarité
nationale et familiale de conjugale
isation des modes de calcul temps des
contributions que de l'accès aux
prestations et c'est un débat qui est
assez passionnant mais je ne suis pas
sûr quand on est le temps de trancher ce
matin la question de la protection des
personnes et de l'horizon d'une
résolution n'est pas fixée ça fait
partie des sujets encore en concertation
donc je ne sais pas y répondre
aujourd'hui et le nombre de personnes
dont la location est contingenté parmi
les bénéficiaires est important donc il
faut qu'on puisse le regarder y compris
d'ailleurs le regarder pour voir combien
sont concernés par un effet de des
conjugale isation et c'est l'objet du
travail des mois qui des mois qui
viennent de la même manière ce que vous
avez évoqué sur la question de la pch et
d'éventuelles revalorisations des
parties plus techniques de la pch doit
faire l'objet d'une discussion avec les
conseils départementaux
il serait assez malvenu je crois que
l'état prenne l'initiative seul en la
matière je peux cependant
en en écho à votre question sur
la situation des bénéficiaires de
l'allocation adultes handicapés qui sont
exposés à des coûts notamment liés aux
déplacements vous dire d'une part et la
réponse vous satisfera pas que le
dispositif que nous prévoyons en l'état
du texte et je sais que ça va faire
l'objet de discussions assez animé est
susceptible de modifier dispositif à
l'assemblée nationale dans l'état du
texte un dispositif réservé aux ménages
pouvant présenter des revenus d'activité
ce qui exclut les bénéficiaires des
minima mais est-ce que l'assemblée a
modifié le dispositif je ne sais le dire
à cet instant par contre et c'est
peut-être plus satisfaisant en tout cas
partiellement les bénéficiaires de la
hache seront tous bénéficiaires de
l'aide exceptionnelle de solidarité que
j'ai annoncée qui bénéficiera 14
millions de personnes que nous avions eu
l'occasion de verser pendant gérer du
coc vide et donc ça permettra d'aider
ces ménages d'une manière
plus spécifiques
vous aviez la comédie s'est associé à
votre question en particulier sur la
question des perdants des gagnants et
des gains ou des pertes de pouvoir
d'achat pour ceux qui seraient concernés
si nous adoptions dispositif de manière
sèche le dispositif de des congés
gallisa sion va bénéficier à 160
l'estimation faite par la dares à 160
mille bénéficiaires de l'aah
160 mille bénéficiaires vont en principe
bénéficier d'une augmentation moyenne et
je dis bien moyenne parce que ça dépend
de la situation de chacun d'environ 300
si le dispositif était adoptée de
manière sèche nous compterions 44 44 à
45 milles perdons pour un montant moyen
de perte de 278 et en termes de coûts
l'estimation faite par la dares là aussi
au mois de juin de cette année estime
que l'augmentation au bénéfice de 160
mille bénéficiaires représentent un coût
légèrement supérieur à 400 millions
d'euros et la compensation des pertes
pour les 44 45 mille paires compte que
je viens d'évoquer représente un coût de
160 millions d'euros ce qui nous amène
un coût total du dispositif tel
qu'estimé par nos services au 1er
juillet à 560 millions d'euros nous
verrons évidemment au fil des mois et
dans le cadre de l'exécution comment
ajuster tout cela
jean marie vanlerenberghe a évoqué les
questions relatives au dividende
salarial c'est aussi une question de
xavier iacovelli donc nous avons fait un
choix qui à la fois de prolonger la
prime exceptionnelle de pouvoir d'achat
pour les salariés gagnant moins de trois
smic dans les entreprises qui le peuvent
jusqu'à fin 2023 et de créer un
dispositif de partage de la valeur
assujettie au même régime fiscal et
social que l'intéressement je n'y
reviens pas nous n'avons pas inscrit
dans ce texte la notion de dividende
salarial aux dividendes aux salariés
considérant que le dispositif est
complexe à mettre en oeuvre que nous ne
pouvons nous heurter à des difficultés
je pense par exemple aux cas de très
petites entreprises dans lesquelles le
chef d'entreprise se rémunère de manière
chiche voire très modeste et à
l'occasion d'une belle année peut se
verser une part du profit mais qui
finalement serait le salaire des bonnes
années plus qu'un dividende sans son
entrain habituel
un grand nombre de partenaires sociaux
nous ont dit leur volonté de travailler
sur le sujet et le medef en particulier
a dit à l'occasion de la réunion du
comité de suivi des négociations
salariales de branche sa disponibilité
pour travailler sur un dispositif de
partage de la valeur et donc de
traduction du dividende salarial le
choix qu'ils ont fait avec la première
ministre et le président de la
république et de laisser aux partenaires
sociaux le temps nécessaire à cette
discussion considérant qu'il n'était pas
nécessairement urgent d'inscrire un tel
dispositif dans un
texte nous vous présentons dans le plfr
que nous vous présentons est que laisser
sa place au dialogue social était aussi
quelque chose d'important de la même
manière sur la question de la solidarité
automatique à moi pour dire c'est un
chantier de longue haleine chantier de
longue haleine rendue possible par deux
choses à la fois la mise en oeuvre du
prélèvement à la source ce qui
aujourd'hui tu me réussit je crois
partagée est constatée par tous et
chantiers permis aussi par la création
de ce qu'on appelle la drm données de
revenus mensuels au sein des organismes
de sécurité sociale le chantier sera de
longue haleine car vraiment travaillé
sur le sujet lorsque j'étais en charge
des comptes publics il faudra dans un
premier temps que la drm et le fichier
du pass soit parfaitement connecté pour
que nous puissions avoir connaissance de
manière simultanée et en temps réel des
revenus fiscaux et sociaux d'un ménage
parce que c'est sur la base des revenus
fiscaux et sociaux que sont calculées
les critères d'éligibilité à telle ou
telle prestation et que ça prend du
temps il est illusoire d'imaginer que
cette connexion pour qu'elles soient
sans risques techniques et sans risques
industriels puissent te faire en moins
d'un an et demi ou deux ont dans un
premier temps les premiers travaux que
nous avions mené montré que cela
rendrait possible l'actualisation de
manière automatique des aides ont
bénéficié un foyer fiscal ou un ménage
mais que dans un premier temps les aides
qui râble resterait qui rappe c'est à
dire que le rsa lacunes d'activité que
vous n'obtenez pas si vous ne demandez
pas devront dans un premier temps à me
demander mais que leur actualisation
voir la fin du droit serait automatisé
et il faudra un deuxième développement
informatique pour que nous passions d'un
système où les aides qui râble soit
versée automatiquement par simple
constatation du niveau de revenus connus
par le foyer ça c'est technique c'est
même pas si dieu
c'est pour souligner que cette dimension
que nous n'abandonnons pas qui serait un
progrès considérable tant en matière de
lutte conte le non recours que de lutte
contre la fraude sociale en l'occurrence
livre déclara-t-il qui ne sont pas
essentiels toujours le rappeler va nous
prendre du temps et que ce temps est
nécessaire pour que le dispositif soit
le plus le plus le plus complet possible
sur la question posée par le sénateur
iacovelli concernant la revalorisation
des retraites et des prestations la loi
indique que ces prestations seront
revalorisées au 1er juillet de l'année
2022 je ne sais pas si aujourd'hui nous
tiendrons les délais du fait du délai
l'adoption du texte pour permettre aux
caisses vous organisez sécurité sociale
de verser les premiers retraites
revalorisées au 9 août pour le régime
général si ça n'était pas le cas et si
le texte était par exemple adopté après
le 5 août le 5 août étant la date du
premier versement des premières retraite
concernés par les premières prestations
concernés par la revalorisation
je n'imagine pas que nous puissions
demander comme gouvernement aux
organismes de sécurité sociale de mettre
en oeuvre un texte que le parlement
n'auraient pas adopter un texte adopté
par le parlement mais n'ayant pas fait
l'objet d'une publication au journal
officiel devrait être mise en oeuvre par
instruction considérant que le parlement
a validé le principe et les dispositions
si ça n'était pas le cas les versements
revaloriser seront décalées mais ça sera
décalée avec un effet rétroactif pour
que cet engagement de revalorisation au
1er juillet soit très bien tenu sur la
prime exceptionnelle de pouvoir d'achat
notre objectif est comment autant de
personnes puissent en bénéficier qu'en
2022 c'est à dire 4 millions de
personnes qui ont pu en bénéficier sur
les questions posées enfin par madame
hubin sur les cotisations d'assurance
maladie des travailleurs indépendants et
leur compensation un mot d'abord pour
dire que c'est pas ma ligne mais avant
tout sur le régime d'autres salaris
d'autres travailleurs et notamment les
salariés et que pour ce qui concerne la
compensation nous sommes dans le cadre
des obligations légales de compensation
par attribution d'une fraction de tva
qui peut être inscrite comme nous
faisons chaque année à l'autre à
l'occasion pardon de l'examen du plfss
et du plf et qu'au delà des dispositions
écrite nous appliquons une obligation
légale vous savez mieux que personne que
le fait de le prononcer devant vous et
de le prononcer comme j'ai fait hier
devant l'assemblée nationale engage le
gouvernement à appliquer ces obligation
est d'ailleurs conforme à ce que nous
avions dit en 2009 18 à l'occasion d'une
19 pardonnez-moi à l'occasion de
l'examen du plan hôpital et d'un débat
sur les heures supplémentaires
je vous confirme ce que là cela
représente 300 millions de du coup que
l'état compensera auprès la sécurité
sociale vous m'avez posé des questions
sur la pardonnez moi je si je n'ai pas
répondu jusque là je l'oubli
c'est donc là miracle voyez j'y crois
tellement peu que je les oublie or en
l'espace de quelques minutes
une actrice rossignol xavier iacovelli
montre combien les représentants de la
majorité présidentielle sont attentifs
aux
revendication portée de longue date par
d'autres groupes au sein du c'est là
l'essentiel l'essentiel c'est d'être
efficace vous savez on est dit les chine
souple on va dire
l'allemande pensait mange
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre pour l'âge dont vous venez
de finir votre intervention
il est vrai cela déjà été quand même d'y
expliquer vous en avez donné une ou deux
raisons la hache n'est pas un minima
social c'est pourquoi il ne devait pas
être d'ailleurs dans le revenu universel
d'activité et puis donc mon collègue est
parti mais dans la loi qui avait été
proposé il y avait un article pour les
perdants donc rien n'a changé de ce
point de vue les raisons voilà il suffit
de dire effectivement que vous avez été
plus salée coûte moi je voudrais
peut-être quand même pointé les faits
quand même d'augmentations des
inégalités salariales de ce genre de
dispositif le pouvoir d'achat
l'inflation importée ou pas touche
touche tous les salariés et tous les
ménages et tous les français et donc je
suis quand même un peu étonné qu'on
puisse porter à 6000 euros
donc multiplié par 3 un dispositif de
primes alors que il hier il nous a été
dit que seuls 5 % des bénéficiaires de
cette prime soit trois cent mille
salariés atteints de 1000 euros et que
le montant moyen vous le savez de duper
panne n'est pas du tout saturés puisque
il est par bénéficiaire de 542 euros
pour ceux qui ne touchent 1 alors au
delà de l'effet d'annoncé dire 3006
mines qui qui aura quand même plus pour
effet de produire je pense de la
frustration par rapport à ceux qui en
seront exclues ça a été dit
croyez vous vraiment qu'il faille
déplafonné encore plus pour une petite
poignée de bénéficiaires creuse en deuil
vos les inégalités salariales et ce
jusqu'à 6000 euros 6000 euros quand même
donc je rappelle qu'en 2021 cela a été
dit cinq entreprises sur six n'ont pas
verser de primes alors que nous le
savons aussi l'effet de taille joue à
plein en faveur plus on est dans les
grandes entreprises plus on est concerné
je crois 29%
si j'ai bonne mémoire et que la prime
déjà et ailier est corrélé à aux
secteurs à forte à forte valorisation à
forte rémunération alors on l'a vu pour
les banques et c'est qui qui qui la
banque assurance immobilier qui ont les
plus grosses primes donc est ce que vous
pensez vraiment que face à une inflation
qui touche tous les français et et plus
les premiers des sinon le singe veut
parler j'ai pas le temps de développer
il est raisonnable de x 3 une prime qui
va accroître encore plus les inégalités
salariales
alors par ailleurs c'est vrai ça a été
dit quand même
cette prime exceptionnelle qui est plus
exceptionnel quand même depuis 2010 ne
sais pas ce qu'on appelle un
exceptionnel qui devient pour moi je le
trouve plutôt une fâcheuse habitude
j'aimerais connaître les évaluations que
vous avez des précédentes prime les
évaluations que vous avez fait sur sur
les effets de cette prime donc dont les
effets sur les inégalités salariales
dont je viens de parler qui vous
conduisent quand même à renouveler
encore et à démultiplier cela alors ces
primes à sont désocialisées
défiscaliser elles ne sont pas compensés
donc 8 milliards qui n'ont pas de deux
enfin ni des sont défiscalisées qui ne
rapporte ni à l'état ni à la sécurité
sociale
je serais quand même tenté de dire que
vous ne pouvez pas dire c'est pas
compensé parce que si on n'avait pas eu
cette prime elles n'auraient pas été
versées rien n'aurait été versé sur ces
8 milliards est ce que c'est vraiment
très raisonnable sur le plan économique
et social de prétendre que aucune enfin
qu'il n'ya pas voilà ce qui s'appelle un
effet de substitution quand même massif
ou du moins partielle ce qu'on appelle
plus prosaïquement un effet d'aubaine et
enfin je serais tenter de vous demander
quelle est la motivation de de cette
possibilité pour l'employeur
d'instaurer un accord en dépit du refus
des salariés enfin quelle place enfin
quelle est la motivation n'est pas
simplement une motivation se pose de
facilitation captens vous donner aux
corps intermédiaires dont vous avez
prétendu que vous les respecte auriez
mieux dans ce cas cana pour ainsi comme
ça valoriser des
non seulement des décisions unilatérales
mais quand même en dépit du refus des
salariés je trouve ça assez incroyable
et enfin bon
c'est toutes ces mesures ne pourraient
ne pourrait ne pas être financée par la
dette qu'est ce que vous vous pensez
pouvoir consentir dans le débat
parlementaire pour avoir des ressources
enfin créer des ressources notamment sur
la taxation
des plus hauts dividendes et
distributions d'évidentes du patrimoine
pour que tout ne partent pas dans la
dette je vous remercie
m
merci il en avait l'occasion monsieur le
ministre si vous permettez j'aurai
quelques remarques et une question très
précise
une première remarque concernant vous
l'avez évoqué la réflexion en tout cas
tout le travail qui est mené auprès des
branches professionnelles par rapport
donc un certain nombre de salariés qui
ne sont pas au niveau du smic
aujourd'hui je me permets juste de vous
alerter ou une nouvelle fois d'attirer
votre attention sur la situation tout à
fait particulière dans nos territoires
d'outre-mer où nous avons eu l'occasion
d'y travailler avec mes collègues et
freddy depuis cinq y est présente sur
notre rapport d'information en france
compétences on voit que l'organisation
on va dire où les organisations dans ces
territoires n'est pas au même niveau que
ce que nous constatons en métropole et
il ne s'agirait pas que ces territoires
soient aussi impacter de manière
négative parce que l'organisation des
branches professionnelles compte tenu de
la spécificité des territoires et de
leurs activités ne sont pas au même
niveau d'organisation ça avait été
soulignée par mes collègues
il ya quelques temps et notamment à
l'occasion de la discussion sur le
projet doivent bien professionnel mais
je me permets de d'en reparler et
d'insister vous êtes vous là dessus mais
autre remarque porte donc sur ce projet
de loi qui est relatif aux mesures
d'urgence pour la protection du pouvoir
d'achat je considère nous considérons je
ne suis pas la seule que ce projet de
loi est tout à fait insuffisant pour
répondre à l'urgence nous le disons mes
collègues et moi mais les organisations
syndicales réunies toutes ensemble dans
une tribune auquel se sont associés les
associations de défense de la jeunesse
ont publié donc une alerte ou ont alerté
le gouvernement le président en première
ligne mais vous-même aussi vous les avez
rencontré en le 7 juillet dernier pour
insister sur le fait que les réponses ou
en tout cas les propositions présentées
dans ce dans ce projet de loi sont
totalement insuffisantes l'urgence
aujourd'hui elle est niée au pouvoir
d'achat très directement et quand on
parle pouvoir d'achat et bien on parle
aussi salaires donc là ce sont des
mesures de maintien ou de développement
ou de renforcement de primes mais rien
sur une augmentation des salaires tels
que nos concitoyens à l'ensemble des
français sont en droit d'attendre des
propositions la fédération des familles
rurales alerte aussi le gouvernement sur
la situation particulièrement difficile
aussi dans les territoires ruraux alors
monsieur le ministre
souhaitons et nous aurons l'occasion au
moment du débat souhaitons que vous
puissiez nous entendre les
parlementaires que nous sommes nous
sommes les représentants de nos
concitoyens et nous relaierons leurs
inquiétudes leurs attentes concernant
donc ces mesures qui doivent répondre
véritablement à une urgence enfin ma
question très précise vous avez indiqué
donc dans l'article 5 des
revalorisations sur les pensions des
prestations sociales en énumérant un
certain nombre de prestations
mais je n'ai pas entendu ce qu'il en est
pour la prime de rentrée scolaire est ce
que la prime de rentrée scolaire sera
aussi concerné par cette revalorisation
quand on sait que là aussi le niveau
d'inflation et l'augmentation des prix
de toutes les fournitures scolaires ne
cesse d'augmenter enfin un véritable
handicap pour bon nombre de deux
familles de jeunes ou de moins jeunes
bien que tient pour se polit ensuite
prenez pas savoir et et laurence
seigneur merci bien
en février 2010 9 marie george buffet à
l'assemblée nationale
défendez la loi sur la d conjugale
isation de la hache
c'était ensuite le 17 juin 2021 nous
l'audition nous déposerons une série
d'amendements un mois j'ai j'ai deux ou
trois questions à vous poser
vous savez que le patron de total a vu
son salaire augmenter de 52 % en 2021 et
que les dividendes ont explosé à tout
niveau 1 elle bat des records on ne voit
plus que ça d'ailleurs comment comptez
vous monsieur le ministre met à
contribution
celles et ceux qui profitent d énormes
difficultés des autres comptez-vous donc
taxer ses dividendes
comptez-vous faire à nouveau quelque
chose sur l'impôt sur la fortune parce
que c'est des recettes qu'on pourrait
quand même à récupérer tout de suite on
en manquait donc là un mois je vous
propose deux mesures immédiates dont
comptez-vous y réfléchir et puis ensuite
ça a été dit
moi je pense notamment à ces chèques que
vous que vous aller distribuer qui ne
sont pas pérennes qui ne faut pas la
maille parce que je pense que
aujourd'hui on voit parler de
revalorisation salariale
je suis de celles qui défendent le smic
à 1500 euros
et puis qui aussi et bien
plaide pour une revalorisation
excusez-moi des retraites parce que
ce sont ces mesures là qu'il faut entrer
des d'argent finalement de par les
cotisations sociales et patronales
dans les caisses de la sécurité sociale
parce que si on continue à faire des
chèques
parce qu'elles sont déjà un mal donc 1
il y as je le rappelle pour les
collectivités locales
les augmentations
de carburant d'énergie comment content
comptez-vous donc compenser ce point
dadis est ma je crois que je vais
arrêter là parce que de toute façon on
aura le débat je sais qu'on a des
réunions de groupe ou alors se tenir
dans cette salle on peut gratter cinq
minutes l'un pas aller au delà
rené paul savary oui monsieur le
ministre je suis pas sûr de soi de votre
compétence mais le sauna bien de
travailler sur le recouvrement des
prestations sociales et nous avons
préconisé
le
2-2 de différer encore d'un an le
recouvrement
par l'urssaf de des prestations de
l'argile qu est ce que vous comptez vous
de vos collègues que prend de cette
décision de report d'un en attendant que
l'urssaf finalistes bien
ccc données nominatives notamment
laurence rossignol vous question porte
merci madame la présidente je vais être
bref vous il y avait incité
deux questions une première qui concerne
l'augmentation du smic j'ai dû
comprendre que à l'assemblée nationale
et à diverses reprises vous vous opposez
à une augmentation du smic pour autant
je vous rappelle que 60 % entre 59 62 %
des salariés au smic sont des femmes
vous connaissez les écarts de
rémunération entre les femmes et les
hommes et la sur représentation des
femmes parmi les salariés au smic est un
des facteurs de cette sueur de cet écart
de salaire vos prédécesseurs is serait
sort avec un ont pris quelques mesures
sur les rémunérations d'égalité
salariale ces mesures concernent quand
même essentiellement des indices de des
indices de mesure entre les pots pour
les écarts mais ça concerne
essentiellement comme les cadres aucune
mesure n'a encore été prise pour les
basses rémunérations je vous demande
donc monsieur le ministre pourquoi vous
vous obstinez à ne pas augmenter le smic
jeu alors je connais toute l'histoire
des négatif du smic et de même vous même
vous l'avait combattu il ya quelques
années donc vous connaissez
l'argumentaire j'imagine pas que vous
l'ayez repris à votre compte d'autant
que je vous parle des salaires des
femmes deuxième chose je crois qu à
l'asssemblée a été adopté en commission
un amendement qui va dans le sens de la
dernière question de ma collègue katia
pourceaux poli c'est à dire de la mise
à charge de l'état des augmentations de
dépenses des collectivités locales
produite induite par l'augmentation du
point d'indicé dans la fonction publique
territoriale
je crois que vous cherchez beaucoup de
d'accord avec le sénat vous compter
beaucoup sur nous j'ai cru comprendre
que la première ministre compter sur
nous pour le projet de loi sanitaire
n'est pas sombre un jouet sanitaires
vous aurez probablement besoin de nous
aussi pour ce texte est-ce que parmi le
bon accord le bon compromis qu'on peut
trouver est ce qu'on pourrait imaginer
que au sénat vous vous souteniez c'est
cet amendement adopté en commission qui
consiste à transférer à l'état la charge
des augmentations du point d'indicé des
salades des salaires des fonctionnaires
territoriaux
merci monsieur le ministre
beaucoup de questions merci madame la
présidente je vais commencer par les
codes les questions qui ne relèvent pas
de mon champ de compétence d'abord
collet pour dire que j'ai entendu mais
aussi pour ne pas laisser ça moi de
réponse qui s'en tirait sur la question
du recouvrement et l'unification du
recouvrement agirc-arrco c'est un
dossier que je connais bien pour l'avoir
suivi aux comptes publics
j'ai vu le rapport de la mission tel que
rendu là je sais que les urssaf ou un
certain nombre d'arguments à faire
valoir en réponse ainsi quand même des
dispositions aux propositions je pense
que la concertation qui est en cours et
à laquelle mon ministère est
nécessairement associés s'agissant d'un
sujet relatif aux cotisations et aux
retraites devra permettre de trouver une
solution je ne sais pas laquelle elle ce
sera cela reste un grand public que du
mien désormais mais c'est un sujet sur
lequel nous aurons l'occasion de
travailler dans les prochains jours et
les prochaines semaines sur les
questions relatives aux au smic abordé
par madame rossignol alain
nous n'avons pas prévu de coup de pouce
si l'on peut dire au smic pour tout un
tas de raisons qui ont été exposées hier
en séance par contre nous sommes malgré
tout dans un mécanisme qui protège
acteurs font que ça change la situation
en matière d'égalité femmes-hommes vous
avez raison mais protecteur puisque au
1er août l'augmentation du smic sur 12
mois sera de 8% du fait des
revalorisations liées à l'inflation soit
un taux supérieur justement à
l'inflation constatée sur 12 mois et
c'est très bien pour la protection du
pouvoir d'achat des treize années de
travailleurs salariés au smic se pose la
question de l'égalité salariale femmes
hommes et notamment de la sur
représentation des femmes parmi les
salariés payés au smic et cette question
se pose indépendamment de la question de
la crise d'inflation que l'on connaît
aujourd'hui l'égalité salariale fait
partie des sujets sur lesquels je
souhaite m'investir tout
particulièrement de même que toutes les
formes de lutte contre les
discriminations de bien avouer que après
six semaines d'exercice je n'ai pas
encore suffisamment avancé pour vous
apporter des réponses précises
aujourd'hui mais nous y travaillons et
je souhaite travailler notamment avec ma
collègue en charge de l'égalité femmes
hommes pour voir tout ce qui peut être
fait et je ne doute pas que vous serez
nous nourrir en propositions diverses et
espère efficace sur ce sujet là vous et
et l'ensemble des différents
parlementaires qui travaillent sur sur
ce sujet sur les questions relatives au
point d'indicé de la fonction publique
ça relève du plfr et non pas du projet
doit pouvoir d'achat
deux éléments malgré tout puisque c'est
un sujet que j'apprécie et que je crois
connaître d'abord pour dire en réponse à
madame
que la situation financière des
collectivités en moyenne parlons
toujours de moyenne et en 2021 un niveau
qui est meilleur que celui connu en 2019
la capacité des parcs des collectivités
en 2021 est très largement supérieure à
celle de 2019 et les dépôts au trésor le
sont aussi la deuxième chose pour
soumettre à votre réflexion le fait que
en matière de revalorisation du point
d'indicé
historiquement l'état n'a jamais
compenser les effets d'une
revalorisation du point d'indicé de la
fonction publique territoriale et je
note d'ailleurs qu'aucune association
d'élus n'a explicitement demandé cette
compensation de la revalorisation du
point d'indicé
cela fait partie finalement d'un accord
global qui fait que les employeurs
territoriaux ont toujours souscrit par
le représentant à l'unicité de la
fonction publique et l'unicité de trois
versants de la fonction publique
l'unicité des trois versants ayant pour
conséquence que la personne hospitalisée
le versant territoriale soit arrivé aux
décisions prises pour ce qui concerne le
versant de l'état et outils des
prérogatives de l'état est-ce qu'il faut
prévoir des dispositifs spécifiques mon
collègue en charge de la cohésion des
territoires qui sauvent béchu et d'un
connecteur d'une curieuse sont sur ce
sujet là et ont une discussion assez
globale ce les relations financières
entre l'état et des collectivités et je
pense que nous devons trouver des
compromis d'ici à l'examen sur les
autres sujets qui ont été abordés j'irai
vite madame la présidente simplement
pour dire que concernant la prime
exceptionnelle de pouvoir d'achat il ya
un certain nombre de représentations que
nous pouvons avoir les uns et les autres
qui s'avèrent fausses vous avez été
nombreux à dire et c'est juste que le
montant moyen de la prime exceptionnelle
de pouvoir d'achat en 2020 21 pardon
elle était de 550 euros j'aurais porté à
la connaissance de votre commission que
le montant moyen de la prime de pouvoir
d'achat dans les entreprises de moins de
dix salariés avec 2 700 euros et est en
réalité est en réalité le
l'effectif de l'entreprise ne fait pas
le montant de la prime et le caractère
inégalitaire que certains cra notamment
madame mange n'est pas vérifiée dans la
mesure où le plafonnement d'éligibilité
la des rémunérations inférieurs à 3 smic
a aussi un effet qui peut-être de
manière contrainte utile et plus et guay
égalitaire qui n'égale iter en matière
de répartition des revenus et et du
partage de la richesse sur les questions
de décisions unilatérales en matière
d'accord d'intéressement votre marque
m'amène à préciser que cette décision
unilatérale n'est possible qu'après
l'échec de la négociation elle ne se
substitue pas totalement à la
négociation mais en cas d'échec ce qui
peut arriver y compris sur des niveaux
sur des cibles le chef d'entreprise
pourra décider unilatéralement de mettre
en place un b un dispositif qui par
définition sera favorable aux salariés
enfin et pardon pour les autres
questions que je n'aurais pas abordée
très directement doré d'autres questions
précises devant nam ferrer de réponse
précise pour ce qui concerne les outre
mer dans le cadre des négociations de
branche les branches professionnelles
lorsqu elles discutent de leurs
conventions et de leur niveau de
rémunération ont la possibilité par la
loi
de créer des dérogations pour tenir
compte des particularités ultramarines
la réalité c'est que très peu de
branches et donc très peu de partenaires
sociaux se saisissent de cette
possibilité mais la loi prévoit d'ores
et déjà une possibilité de dérogation à
la règle de branche pour les territoires
ultramarins et enfin vous m'interrogez
sur la question de l'allocation rentrée
scolaire je vous confirme qu'elle fait
partie du train de revalorisation à 4%
elle sera versée à partir du 17 août
j'en suis confus je le prie de m'excuser
j'avais noté que laurent burgoa voulait
poser une question on n'avait pas marqué
sur la liste donc laurent burgoa
tout excuser ce n'est pas grave monsieur
mais ce que je veux y revenir quand même
quelques instants parce que sur
les foules à ce que certaines mesures
vont avoir sur les budgets des
collectivités permettez-moi de pas être
du tout d'accord avec les rapports qui
actuellement floris parce que les
rapports c'est bien mais la réalité du
terrain on la connaît tous moi je
rencontre pas un élu local dans le gard
qui me dis pas que c'est budget votre
plus en plus contraire je voudrais bien
voir vos rapports mais je pense que ces
rapports sont des gens qui sont
déconnectés de la réalité est que
lorsque vous êtes sur le terrain les
élus municipaux départementaux
tout est une bonne chose je crois que là
l'augmentation du point d'indicé
l'augmentation de 4 % du rsa il n'y a
aucun élu ici autour de la table qui va
aller contester mais l'augmentation de 4
% du rsa par exemple ça va avoir comme
conséquence une augmentation pour le
budget départements du gard de 7,2
millions d'euros où trouver cela
monsieur moi je veux bien mais la
réalité va donc et est très clair et je
rejoins ma collègue apparaît solide pour
dire que on a bien pris en compte que
d'un discours de politique générale
madame la première ministre a fait un
animal amour au sénat
c'est des paroles incendiaires nous
attendons les actes maintenant et dans
l'exacte where do très clair s'il n'y a
pas de compensation
partielle ou totale rapport ces mesures
là je vous le dit monsieur le ministre
c'est la fin de certaines collectivités
territoriales par ses côtés de laquelle
on faire le choix de ne plus investir
dans de plus investir ça veut dire qu'
il n'y aura plus d'emplois localement
dans nos départements
pas à monsieur le ministre j'ai juste
pour dire c'est l'instrument timerman
juste une question mais dire à monsieur
le sénateur qui ne s'agit pas de
rapports faits par des personnes
déconnecté il s'agit simplement de la
prise en compte des balances comptable
dont nous disposons des chiffres dont le
trésor public dispose par la compilation
des comptes des collectivités et des
chiffres qui sont généralement année
après année partagée par l'ensemble des
instances y compris le comité des
finances locales et je les dis il s'agit
de moyennes et les moyennes les ratios
concernant le secteur des collectivités
montre que dans son ensemble secteur des
collectivités et est excédentaire c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle ça ne veut pas
dire que derrière il n'ya pas des
disparités entre collectivités j'ai
toujours dit et le maire j'ai été
pendant dix ans je le sais aussi bien
que beaucoup d'entre vous je crois tout
comme le député que je suis d'une
circonscription qui compte 92 communes
de toutes tailles dont je sais très bien
ces disparités
la semaine prochaine on n'espère
pas trop tard dans la semaine prochaine
pour continuer le débat merci bonne
journée à vous